practically speaking
how should we leverage sadness for
creativity
is that
sort of in the artist domain in the
writer's domain in the uh engineering
domains and so on it's definitely in
those domains but it's in all domains um
you know we're all going to face pain in
this life at some point and we all have
the ability to
weather it and with withstand it and
live with it for a bit and then try to
transform it into something that we find
beautiful
um you know and
it's very easy to
to notice the grandeur of like the you
know the painting hanging on the gallery
wall or the new company that's just been
created but it takes a thousand
different forms right you know you could
bake a cake or like
in the wake of the pandemic we've had
more people applying to medical school
and nursing school and after 9 11 you
had people applying for jobs as
firefighters and teachers
so there's something in the human spirit
that
takes pain and turns it into meaning
when we're at our best
and when we're not at our best we deny
the pain and then take it out on
ourselves and on other people so there's
a kind of fork in the road of what to do
with it
but we know i mean there's all these
studies that i go through in the book
there was one
where
the researchers had people watch
different movies like happy movies sad
movies bittersweet movies um and they
found when people watched father of the
bride which is like the ultimate
bittersweet you know you're walking
your daughter down the aisle kind of
feeling that was
they would give them creativity tasks
after watching these different movies
and the people who had been primed for
bitter sweetness were the most creative
they were like primed to remember
finality you know like love and finality
basically
love and impermanence
there's something about that that's
that gets us to our most beautiful state
i wonder if it is i mean there's studies
like that there's a i don't know if you
looked into the terror management theory
yeah that's really interesting so they
especially intensely
have you focused on not just sad but
uh traumatic like death
priming you with death and see how that
changes your mind
like both like i don't i don't know if
there's creativity studies but they have
um interesting
i think a little bit tainted by
political bias but maybe not i mean
psychology is a complicated field but
they they study like who are you likely
to vote for right if you're primed by
existential like by thinking about the
fear of
fear mortality i forget what the
conclusions are but i i think they find
that people become more tribalistic yeah
you know like there was one study where
they found that after they primed people
that way that um
that they would get then give them the
chance to put
hot sauce on a meal that their political
opponents were going to be eating and
they put way too much hot sauce on
after they've been primed to worry about
death
i think at the core
we're simple creatures
so i actually like in the book i i spent
a bunch of time with people who are
working on
radical life extension you know or
the quest to live forever
and people ask them a lot questions like
you know the kinds of questions you were
talking about earlier well like how are
you going to feed everybody and how is
there going to be space for everybody um
if everyone really could live forever
and um and what about conflict when we
have an intensified conflict
and their answer to that is
they point to terror management theory
you know and they say
because it's the fear of death
they're basically saying it's the fear
of death that are causing our conflicts
in the first place and that if we
removed the fear of death
we'd have
less conflict to contend with and that i
don't really buy that
it's possible that that's true but are
you also
how does the expression go throwing out
the baby with the bath water i are you
also going to remove basically
any source of meaning
and um
happiness in the human condition
like it's very possible that death is
fundamental to the human condition the
finality
yeah
that's the great philosophical question
and i went to a conference of of people
who are working on this and i thought
that they were going to be talking about
those questions all through the
conference but
the mo is much more like
we're so happy that we're here with
people who have gotten past all those
quibbles um yeah you know we just know
there's going to be meaning no matter
what the basic assumption is
let's try to extend life
indefinitely and then we'll figure out
if that's a good decision
or more like we're sure it's a good
decision or
at least
that was what i felt it's it's it's
either way
sure it's either we're sure
it's a good decision
or
we're sure that it's good to believe
that it's a good decision
meaning like there's no downside uh to
to that even if we find out it's wrong
but yes there's a kind of certainty
obviously you want to extend human life
that's the kind of assumption that
always seemed
now
it could be true
but just like the people who
over focus on
colonizing other planets
it feels like you neglect the beauty
and the the the struggle of our life
here on earth i have sort of the same
kind of criticism whether it's thinking
about valhalla or any other afterlife
is you
can have if you're not careful
forget to uh to make this life a great
one
whatever happens after afterwards so
yeah definitely but from an engineering
from a biology from a chemistry
perspective it's very interesting to
think
how do we extend this thing because it
does seem that nature the way it
designed
living organisms
it really wants us to die
because that's part of the selection
mechanism this part this seems to be
fundamental to evolution
it uh gets
because people young they need
protection once they once their young
brain they get to explore a lot get to
figure out the world to come up their
own novel ideas how to
adapt and how to respond to that world
and then as you get older and older they
get like stubborn and stuck in their
ways
and so we need them to die so we make
room for
new
life that's able to adapt to the
changing environment if the old doesn't
die
then you're not you're going to get
stale and
not be adaptable to the changing
environment but maybe it doesn't have to
happen so soon
yeah maybe it doesn't it's like pressing
listen i'm a big fan of pressing snooze
on the alarm clock
in the same way
um i do i'm one of the people that
believe it's
or i don't definitely believe of course
i'm
i don't know but i think
death is a
is a fundamental part of life
uh but yeah if i'm on my deathbed i
would sure as hell press snooze as many
times as possible yeah i know and it's
interesting because i in some ways i
really i share your instinct um there
was one scientist who i spoke to at that
conference he's one of the leading
advocates and he said
you know that's a story that we've
invented for ourselves because we have
no choice and if you really believe that
you have no choice then you're then it's
adaptive to tell that story that death
gives meaning to life good point but if
you really think you don't if you really
think you could triumph over it would
you still be telling that same story and
i've been thinking about that question
ever since
yeah yeah no they got a good point they
got a good point no matter what as an
engineering and a scientific pursuit
it's a beautiful one
you